good morning believe nation if you want
to run a great business then I'm going
to share with you a clip from Warren
Buffett on what he says kills most
businesses and how you can avoid it
well what kills great businesses if you
look at I do believe in looking at
history and I and I try to I like to
study failure actually then my partner
says all I want to know is where I'll
die so I'll never go there and and we
want to see what has caused businesses
to go bad and the biggest thing that
kills them is complacency I mean you you
want a restlessness a feeling that you
know that that somebody is always after
you but you're going to stay ahead of
them you always want to be on the move
and and when you've got a great business
you know like coca-cola wishes there
aren't any like oh girl but but really
the danger would always be the you rest
on your laurels but I see none of that
obviously a coca-cola but that's that
that is the key to compete the same way
when you've got 1.8 billion servings
being sold daily as when you were
selling you know 10 a day and and that
restlessness that belief that that
tomorrow's more exciting than today you
know you just have to have it permeate
the organization so this video reminds
me of a friend of mine when she started
her business she loved it she was all in
she was networking she was meeting
people she was landing new deals she was
getting new business she was growing her
company she built it up to a certain
size and then for some reason she lost
the passion her heart just wasn't into
it anymore and she started looking for
other things to do and I remember
telling her listen if you don't love
this anymore then sell it find somebody
to sell it to because you're going to
get a decent price to where you're at
now and you don't have to worry about
the responsibilities of this business
and you can go focus on doing something
that you love and her response was yeah
I could sell it but it's giving me
passive income and I just want to to
have this thing that I can put on
autopilot and have somebody else run for
me and then I can worry about other
things here's what always happens with
entrepreneurs who try to put their
business
auto pilot this it never stays the same
it never goes up it always declines and
whether that's a fast decline or slow
decline it declines because you took
your eye off the ball no one's gonna
care for it as much as you do and you're
now off to other projects and so your
business is going to decline so my
friend now two years later comes back to
me and says hey I'm thinking about
selling my business I should have
listened to you two years ago what do I
do now
and I'm kicking myself because I wish
that I was more forceful with her before
I wish it I really got that point home
to her more because now she's two years
later her business has declined a little
bit and she can't get as good a price on
her business as she could have before so
stop thinking about putting your
business on autopilot
stop being complacent about what you're
doing pour your heart and your energy
and your soul into your business and if
you don't love it enough anymore to put
that kind of energy and dedication into
it then sell it off to somebody and get
a return on it and move on to something
else that you're passionate about
believe thank you guys for watching I'd
love to know your thoughts can you run a
great company and put it on autopilot
leave it in the comments below I'd love
to hear from you and if you liked this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the newsletter
and the channel thanks for watching have
an amazing day and I hope to see you
again as you start your morning tomorrow
off of my channel with another
inspirational video